Trascrizione: Roberto Minelli
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Lo sapete che in Italia c'è una legge
che ci dice quanto devono
essere grandi le nostre case?
È una legge piuttosto vecchia, del 1975.
Ci dice, ad esempio,
che la casa più piccola possibile -
ovvero un monolocale per una persona -
deve misurare almeno 28 metri quadri.
Invece, per case più grandi,
a noi architetti viene chiesto
di avere 12 metri quadri
per ogni abitante.
E poi ci dice pure la dimensione,
delle varie stanze:
ad esempio, una camera singola,
per essere considerata abitabile -
quindi non essere un ripostiglio -
deve essere almeno nove metri quadri.
Ma voi sapete quanto sono,
nove metri quadri?
È fondamentale avere
la percezione dello spazio,
e delle cose che ci circondano
tutti i giorni;
ed è per questo che io, di solito,
giro sempre con con un metro,
lo porto sempre con me.
Non questo, ma la mia stessa mano.
Ho misurato che aperta, più o meno,
misura circa venti centimetri:
e quindi, in questo modo misuro ogni cosa,
anche lo spazio qui, diciamo,
attorno a voi - questa platea -
perché voglio aiutarvi
a capire, effettivamente,
quanto sono nove metri quadri.
Aiutatemi: cercate la persona che siede
otto posti alla vostra destra,
o alla vostra sinistra.
Se siete al centro -
no no, guardatevi pure -
se siete al centro, magari,
quattro posti a destra
e quattro posti a sinistra;
e poi quella che siede davanti,
tre file davanti a voi
e tre file dietro di voi.
Ecco: immaginate un rettangolo
che unisce voi e queste persone,
ed eccovi la vostra cameretta
di nove metri quadri.
Ve l'aspettavate così grande,
oppure pensate sia piccola?
Eppure, guardate quante persone
possono entrare in soli nove metri quadri:
praticamente, potreste fare
quasi un mini TED a casa vostra.
Eppure le nostre camere,
piuttosto, sono così:
piene di mobili, pieni di oggetti,
che quasi forse nemmeno
una sola persona ci può entrare.
A me è andata un po' diversamente,
perché quando ero piccolo ho scoperto
di avere un'allergia alla polvere
e quindi i miei genitori
mi hanno assegnato
una camera molto piccola,
di soli sette metri quadri,
questa che vedete.
E come potete notare,
non ho tanti oggetti:
non ho nemmeno un armadio.
Questa camera mi ha insegnato,
senza che io lo sapessi,
ad avere uno stile di vita
che oggi definiremmo minimalista.
E poi, lo spazio ridotto
mi ha in qualche modo obbligato
a iniziare a ragionare come un architetto.
Quindi, in questa camera
ho fatto tutto il mio mondo:
quando ero piccolo, per giocare;
e poi, durante l'adolescenza,
per chiudere la porta
e lasciare tutto il mondo fuori,
un po' come fa ogni adolescente.
Ne sono uscito solamente quando ho deciso
di studiare all'università:
mi sono trasferito a Bologna,
e ho scelto di studiare architettura.
Ed è proprio qui
che un professore, a un esame,
guardando un mio progetto,
mi disse un po' arrabbiato:
ma non hai studiato la legge del 75!
Non vedi che questa camera
non misura nemmeno nove metri quadri?
Ritorni alla prossima revisione.
Potete immaginare, ovviamente,
che io non l'abbia presa molto bene,
perché ovviamente ho dovuto
riprogettare tutto.
Ma soprattutto perché io,
fino a pochi mesi prima,
abitavo in una camera
di soli sette metri quadri.
Quindi vuol dire che i miei genitori
mi avevano fatto vivere in un ripostiglio?
Effettivamente -
Eppure, io stavo bene.
Non sarà, forse,
che non contano i metri quadri a stabilire
la qualità abitativa di una casa?
E quindi, questa è diventata un po'
la mia missione da architetto:
volevo dimostrare
che in quei nove metri quadri
potevo realizzarci tutta una casa -
non solo una camera singola,
quindi con la cucina e il bagno -
e una casa di grandissima qualità.
Del resto, avevo appena
finito l'università,
e dovevo necessariamente trovarmi
un posto dove andare a vivere
per non tornare a casa dei miei genitori,
quindi per essere indipendente.
E quindi, ho cercato
tutti gli annunci possibili
di vendita di case, stanze, soffitte
di nove metri quadri;
e ne avevo trovata una a Bologna,
con una vista a 360 gradi
su tutta la città.
Ma questo non bastava:
perché volevo viaggiare,
volevo vedere il mondo.
Volevo viverlo come un abitante,
non come un turista.
E quindi ho pensato: ma perché non mettere
questi nove metri quadri su ruote,
per poter vivere
e viaggiare come un nomade?
È così che ho iniziato a disegnare
la mia "Tiny House";
che in italiano significa "mini casa".
Qui in Italia, probabilmente,
sono stato il primo:
ma nel mondo ci sono centinaia di persone
che hanno deciso di costruirsela
e vivere in spazi ridotti,
magari rinunciando a tantissimi oggetti
che avevano prima
nella loro casa molto grande.
Ho costruito questa casa
affinché fosse piccolissima,
leggera e aerodinamica,
perché volevo poterla trasportare ovunque,
solamente agganciandola un'automobile,
e quindi poter essere libero di spostarmi
dalla campagna alla città,
andare a vivere in montagna con la neve;
e quindi, da questo terrazzo
che ho costruito sul tetto,
potete vedere qualsiasi
panorama possibile.
All'interno, invece,
è uno spazio che si evolve.
Ogni volta posso aprire,
da questo vuoto grigio iniziale,
un nuovo arredo di color legno;
e trasformare questo vuoto
in una stanza diversa.
Sembra veramente di avere
infinite stanze dentro un unico spazio.
Ad esempio, qui apro questo pannello
e tac - ho una camera da letto.
Non solo per una persona:
anche per due persone,
perché il materasso si trasforma.
E poi il gioco riinizia,
quindi richiudo tutto, e il vuoto
ritorna a essere disponibile.
Ad esempio, apro questi due pannelli
e tac, che ho un openspace con cucina -
non ve lo aspettavate, probabilmente.
E poi, qui dietro nel muro
è nascosto anche un tavolo:
e quindi, ovviamente,
ho la mia sala da pranzo,
fino a poter ospitare
anche quattro persone.
E poi, chiaramente,
dietro altri pannelli c'è un bagno,
con una doccia che si trova sul pavimento,
la posso aprire dal pavimento.
E poi posso richiudere tutto
in poche mosse,
e alla fine ho anche una sala
per fare palestra.
Quindi, insomma, le stanze
sono veramente infinite.
Forse, a qualcuno di voi
sarà venuto in mente qualcun altro
che ha avuto un esperienza di vita simile:
non nella realtà, ma in un film.
Forse qualcuno si ricorda Renato Pozzetto,
ne "Il ragazzo di campagna".
Interpretava un giovane contadino
che si trova per la prima volta
a vivere in città.
E l'unico appartamento
che trova in affitto
è un minuscolo monolocale tutto grigio,
con arredi trasformabili -
anche senza finestra.
Molto bizzarro, ma veramente simile
alla mia Tiny House.
Pensate che, 40 anni dopo,
io sono, senza nemmeno saperlo -
perché non avevo mai visto
quel film prima d'ora -
sono arrivato più o meno
allo stesso risultato.
Nel 1984, il regista aveva,
con lo scenografo,
ideato questo appartamento
per far ridere, per fare satira.
Io invece volevo viverci
in questa casa, realmente.
Quindi, effettivamente,
le cose sono cambiate da allora.
Il mondo dei micro appartamenti è reale,
è un mercato immobiliare reale.
Pensate che a Milano, qualche anno fa,
ho trovato un annuncio di vendita
di un microappartamento
di 11 metri quadri.
E lo vendevano a circa
5.900€ al metro quadro.
Voi direte: speculazione edilizia?
Cosa ci sta raccontando,
questo architetto?
Beh, in parte è vero, è così.
Però vediamola, anche,
da un'altra prospettiva.
Questo appartamento era così piccolo
che si poteva trovare
nel centro della città,
vicinissimo a tutti i trasporti
e tutti i servizi.
Quindi, probabilmente,
la persona che oggi l'ha acquistato
non avrà bisogno di un'automobile.
E poi, è così piccolo
che sicuramente non si potrà permettere
di accumulare tantissimi oggetti.
Quindi, sostanzialmente,
vivere in uno spazio piccolo
ci obbliga in qualche modo,
necessariamente,
ad avere uno stile di vita
più consapevole e più sostenibile.
Non so se lo sapete, ma qualche giorno fa
la popolazione mondiale ha raggiunto
gli otto miliardi di abitanti.
E presto, sul pianeta saremo 11 miliardi.
Allora è necessario iniziare
a pensare, effettivamente,
a quanto spazio
abbiamo bisogno per vivere.
Qualche mio collega architetto
sta già progettando case su Marte.
Ma non è forse meglio pensare
cosa potremmo fare qui noi, tutti,
per diminuire il nostro
impatto sul pianeta?
Del resto, questi 28 metri quadri
sono realmente necessari?
In realtà, noi ne occupiamo molti di più.
Le statistiche, a parte il Giappone
che diciamo ne occupano solo 22,
ci dicono, ad esempio,
che negli Stati Uniti, mediamente,
ogni persona possiede 90 metri quadri
di superficie abitativa,
e in Italia 67.
Se vogliamo misurarla come prima,
possiamo considerare
circa metà di questa platea.
Be', io con la mia tiny House
ho abbassato questa media;
però queste dimensioni, in realtà,
stanno solo crescendo.
Ma com'è possibile?
I nostri cellulari
stanno diventando più piccoli,
i nostri computer sono più piccoli,
persino le nostre auto:
abbiamo abbandonato ormai i SUV,
e stanno diventando piccolissime.
E le nostre case?
E poi, di tutto questo spazio,
cosa ce ne facciamo?
Non siamo quasi sempre fuori casa?
Qualcuno mi guarda, e penserà forse
al periodo della quarantena:
Ne abbiamo passato
di tempo in casa, quei giorni.
Però, ormai siamo alla normalità.
Dobbiamo guardare avanti.
Quando abbiamo tanto spazio,
cerchiamo di riempirlo.
Gli psicologi ci dicono
che abbiamo, forse, paura del vuoto.
Io ho progettato la mia casa, sul vuoto.
E quindi, compriamo
e riempiamo le nostre case;
poi ne compriamo una più grande,
e la riempiamo di nuovo.
Una giornalista americana ha stimato
che possediamo circa
300.000 oggetti a persona.
Ma tutti questi oggetti che possediamo,
quasi sempre inutili,
ci rendono davvero felici?
E poi, non è solo una questione di spazio:
pensate alla loro produzione,
al loro trasporto,
ormai fino al nostro zerbino di casa,
alla vendita.
Questo non è sostenibile,
per il nostro pianeta.
Eppure, quando viaggiamo
non siamo abituati a mettere tutto
dentro una valigia,
in pochissimi centimetri cubi?
Eppure siamo felici, in quel momento.
Forse perché lasciamo a casa le cose,
ma anche i pensieri
che appesantiscono la nostra vita.
E io lo so bene
cosa significa appesantire,
perché nella mia Tiny House
devo rispettare, necessariamente,
un peso massimo che è di 3500 chili:
se no, appena mi ferma la Polizia
mi fa la multa, chiaramente.
E quindi sono abituato a essere
molto limitato, nel possedere gli oggetti.
Ma questo non limita la mia felicità.
Anzi, pensate che quando compro qualcosa,
se devo necessariamente comprare qualcosa,
mi viene tantissima ansia:
provo un'ansia a possedere le cose.
Ovviamente, anch'io ho qualcosa di futile,
qualcosa a cui tengo tantissimo.
Queste sono le tazze che ho comprato
durante il mio ultimo viaggio,
prima della pandemia, in Giappone.
Le ho pure rotte, e le ho riaccomodate,
e sono ancora lì;
e non mi servivano,
perché avevo chissà quante tazze,
dentro la mia casa.
Quindi, alle cose importanti
non dobbiamo obbligatoriamente rinunciare.
Forse qualcuno di voi è stato convinto
da questo,mio discorso,
e sta pensando:
ma io che ho una casa grande,
ormai sono pieno di oggetti.
Cosa posso fare? Dove posso incominciare?
Beh, fate presto:
potete cercare su internet
questa parola inglese,
che è stata coniata apposta:
"Decluttering".
Vi insegneranno, tantissimi blogger,
i metodi per poter ridurre
i propri oggetti:
ma poi ognuno ha un po' il suo, di metodo.
Io avevo istituito, da piccolo,
una giornata apposta chiamata "Butta Day",
probabilmente perché volevo
convincere mia sorella,
che al mio contrario,
è un accumulatrice seriale.
Ma non significa che bisogna,
per forza, buttare via le cose -
o meglio riciclatele, se potete.
Potete rivenderle;
potete regalarle a qualcuno.
Ormai ci sono app
che ci permettono di fare annunci,
e vendere le nostre cose,
in pochissimi click.
Oppure, le nostre VHS
o gli archivi che abbiamo
possiamo metterli in un hard disk,
che misura pochi centimetri.
Invece, quando dobbiamo acquistare
qualcosa di nuovo,
dobbiamo pensare:
ma ne abbiamo realmente bisogno?
Ci serve a qualcosa?
Possiamo prenderlo
in prestito da un amico?
Possiamo noleggiarlo?
Ormai, le app di sharing economy
ci permettono di non
possedere più un'auto,
o non possedere più un tagliaerba.
Pensate che a Bologna, nel 2016,
è nata la prima biblioteca degli oggetti,
dove tu porti quello che non ti serve
e prendi in prestito le cose
che magari utilizzi
solo una volta all'anno.
Non è geniale?
E invece, quando proprio
dobbiamo acquistare qualcosa,
dobbiamo necessariamente ragionare bene,
come ho fatto io
per comprare questa giacca.
Dobbiamo comprare qualcosa
che ci piaccia davvero,
che sia fuori dalle mode passeggere -
pensate al fast fashion:
che abbia un design intelligente;
che sia sostenibile;
che sia multifunzione.
In questo modo, possiamo selezionare
gli oggetti che abbiamo.
E poi, una volta che abbiamo ridotto
i nostri oggetti, cosa possiamo fare?
Ormai abbiamo una casa grande!
Be', se siete stati bravi
forse avrete liberato, anche,
una stanza intera della vostra casa.
E a questo punto potreste, ad esempio,
dedicarla a un hobby che avete,
a cui non potevate dedicare
uno spazio prima.
Oppure, vi dò un'altra idea
che magari quest'anno può anche aiutarvi
a ridurre le spese di riscaldamento,
visto che, sapete, le bollette
aumenteranno tantissimo.
Beh, forse anche la crisi energetica
ci può insegnare a vivere
in maniera più essenziale.
Guardate questo appartamento:
è l'appartamento dei miei genitori.
Sto cercando di convincerli
a ridimensionarsi.
È un appartamento comune,
probabilmente molto simile
a quello di tutti voi.
Quindi c'è un salotto sulla sinistra,
poi una cucina, un bagno
e tre camere -
o meglio, scusate:
due camere e un ripostiglio.
Ormai l'avete capito.
Cosa si può fare?
La normativa ci permette - quelle statali,
ma quelle regionali, e anche
i regolamenti dei condomini -
ci permettono di frazionare
i nostri appartamenti,
sempre chiaramente rispettando
quelle regole che ormai conoscete bene.
E vedete, con pochissime mosse
è possibile trasformare una casa grande,
magari inutilizzata in parte,
in due appartamenti.
E quindi creare un nuovo monolocale
che può essere affittato, oppure venduto;
e questo ci permette,
magari, di viaggiare di più,
comprare un camper
per viaggiare sulle colline,
o una tiny house.
E quindi, ci permette
di essere più liberi,
perché abbiamo più tempo, anche,
da dedicare agli altri,
alle persone che amiamo.
Be', io con la mia Tiny House
ho dovuto rinunciare a tantissime cose:
però, avere una casa piccola e leggera
mi ha permesso di fare
tantissime esperienze on the road,
e di incontrare ogni volta
tantissimi nuovi vicini di casa
che sono diventati degli amici.
Quindi sono molto contento,
di questa scelta che ho fatto:
mi ha reso più libero.
Ecco, non tutti devono per forza vivere
in una casa su ruote
di pochi metri quadri.
Ognuno può trovare la propria strada
per vivere in maniera più essenziale.
Ad esempio rinunciando a una stanza,
o un piano della propria casa,
o semplicemente facendo ordine
negli oggetti che possediamo.
Perché tutti dobbiamo, in qualche modo,
contribuire a rendere la nostra
impronta abitativa, come umani -
affinché la nostra presenza qui
sia più sostenibile.
Quindi per il nostro pianeta,
ma alla fine anche per noi stessi.
Grazie mille.
(Applausi)